so today which is the
18th of July
we are going to
focus our attention to neural networks
and their applications
now there's one component.
In a neural network called a convolutional layer and what
kind of Illusion is a certain?
Matrix operation
and this
convolution operation is key to
all the applications of neural networks.
So if we want to
you know detect
a character
in a picture
I can Optical calculate recognition convolution plays
a key part.
if we want to find out why certain factors
cause the price
of a realistic property increase or decrease
again convolution plays an important part
So that's a regression example, I gave you
a classification example.
and
another important component of a new network is the
linear transformation now to really understand what
You know what in your network?
is made of
And how it works and why it's so effective.
We need to look at neural Xbox from two perspectives.
one will be a
pictorial representation of a neural network
And then there is the Matrix representation of the neural network. So
neural networks are Matrix operations.
But to it really does help to see these
operations at the high level and pictureally
at least in the form of graphs and then the
form of diagrams.
Added a process. We are going to
also use some.
data
So if you want to predict something on data if you want to classify an
image.
Data will also need to have access to
that data.
And the best way to read this data will be using the library pandas.
Okay, so you
how many of you here have any familiarity with the pandas Library?
If you are familiarity with the Panthers Library type and
why otherwise type in it.
Even if the answer is no by the way.
It's very simple thing to use that. Well, at least we're not
going to use we're not going to do anything complicated with patterns. We're just going to read.
some tabular data
and look at things like mean like the
what we call the summary statistics.
Actually, we want to see what is the mean average is what is the median? What
are the number number of data? We have that kind
of thing.
Now we didn't actually get to cover.
PCA we've covered the most important parts of the
PC. We've covered the mathematics of the PC.
although we haven't quite
seen its application.
So here's what I want us to do. I want to actually start up
with this.
and let me rename this to
example of PCA
or dimensionality reduction
You see one of the things we will have to do.
for our
regression example is to reduce the dimensionality of the data.
So there are two it's a two-step process first. We will
import our data with pandas.
Which will have many columns.
In other words, it will have large dimensionality.
Well, then use PCA to reduce the dimensionality.
And once we have reduced the dimensionality instead of the original
columns will have these things called principle components which you
will look at today.
and what we've reduced them in charity we can then use neural networks
to
do all sorts of things on this data.
You'll find clusters in that data.
To classify the label of the data.
to perform regression on the data
and I'm hoping that in these next three sessions will get to
see all three examples regression classification and clustering.
number two
after I've showed you a very simple example of PCA we are
going to
well
introduce ourselves to
neural networks
So we get we will begin the high level.
We will talk about something called the input layer.
the hidden layers
and the one output layer
we will talk about
something called the activation
of
Something called a perceptron again a couple
of terminology here like these are these
are terms and deep learning now. We
deep learning.
Is a technique that uses neural networks?
So deep learning is a technique that uses matrices put
in some special arrangement.
And these are the components of a neural network. And this is the most Atomic component
of a neural network.
And we'll see what this is.
And hopefully we'll be able to cover this fast enough so that
in our next session we can actually use these two
together.
We can create a machine learning.
pipeline
let's begin.
I'm going to switch over to colab.
whoops
Pi tutorial number 17
I will import numpy.
as MP and
Matlab and
math
lot lib
so we can see what principal components are.
And then we can visualize them.
import math, so it's
ation
What I'm going to show you is a matrix.
There is two by six.
So it has two columns and six six rows.
This is a very simple Matrix and it's just and it's
small enough so that we can
You know get the get the point of PCA and then
of course.
In the next example, we will look at a large.
Dataset so this one only has two dimensions.
Ultimately, what we want to do is we want to project this two-dimensional.
Data onto one. I want dimensional into one
dimension. So we want to go from
essentially two vectors to one vector. Let me
explain what I mean.
So we are going to perform SVD on this.
Okay, and remember we said that PC is a special case of SVD.
To remind you what SVD is?
Let me bring you back to the tutorial from our last session.
suppose we have the Matrix a
what we will do.
Is factorize this Matrix again SVD is
a matrix factorization method.
Well factored, it is three matrices USV.
before I tell you what u and v are
S is the Matrix that contains the
singular values?
And the context of PC we call these singular values their principle
components.
when we multiply
the singular values
In PC, which are called principle components when we
come when we multiply by that we need to argue values. Okay, so singular values
are eigenvalues
and these eigenvalues in principle component large are called principal
components.
So these are eigenvalues.
when we multiply
in PCA when we multiply one of these eigenvalues by
The Matrix of the left
Or I should say the column vectors
in The Matrix Matrix on the left. We will get
these vectors that will show us
How the data has been reduced?
But let me just quickly tell you how what the
factorization how the factorizations perform. So
in order for us to get to you.
We multiply a by itself but we
actually transpose it first. So we take the
transpose of Matrix a multiplied by itself.
To get Ada. I will call at a
the transpose of
a times a
then we will do it the other way round. So we'll multiply
a times the transpose of a we'll get a second Matrix.
in order to get to matrices u and
v transpose
we have to orthonormalize these matrices.
And we talked about what it takes to orthonormalize these two
matrices.
It ultimately comes down to a technique called
The gram Schmidt algorithm we talked
about this in the previous session if you watched if you weren't here yes before
yesterday you watch the recording you.
The grams she was process.
the gram Schmidt algorithm
will orthogonalize
The Matrix and also normalize it
again to normalize a vector
is to
divide that back divide the components of
that vector by the norm of that vector.
basically
the components will
all have values between 0 and 1
That's what normalization is and that's why I'm I made
an orthogonal Matrix is called orthonormal because it's
an orthogonal Matrix with components have been.
normalized
and of course in order to find the
singular values aka the principal components aka
the eigenvalues we perform.
You know, I get the composition like we saw.
in the session before the last
okay.
Where we I mean, I don't have it here. But I hope you
remember this this tabs for oh, you know
decomposing a matrix.
So we get 14.14 from
Well, we can get this we can both we can get both eigenvalues from
decomposing. Excuse me. I can decomposition of both
matrices u and v decomposition of both matrices will
reveal both.
of these eigenvalues
All right. Let's return here. Now. We're
not going to do this. We're not going to use grab Schmidt
and normalization. We're just going to use a
built-in method of
numpy called SVD. So there's a method called
NP.
It's a SVD in the object linear algebra.
And its return value will be 3.
Things and we will start well, it
will be two matrices and one vector.
But you will assign to you.
As and V.
So the return value of this method will be a matrix Vector
Matrix respectively.
and after all and that's this SVD composition
And then I'll print all three.
Variables so print you.
And S and V.
So this is the Matrix U.
the eigenvalues
there will be put in the
Matrix
SS for Sigma, okay.
In a PCA the S is a sigma use the
Greek letter.
And the Matrix V.
All right.
The next thing we are going to do is I'm going to
put these eigenvalues.
in an identity Matrix
So again, you see here. This is an identity Matrix.
But instead of once we have the argument value, so I'm going to produce this
Square Matrix.
and to do this
first
I will assign.
lowercase s to uppercase s because the
convention you know, we want to follow linear algebra convention
where
a we use the we use a lowercase dollars to
denote the vectors uppercase that is to denote matrices.
so I'm going to change uppercase as to small as
uppercase s instead will be a matrix.
If you see this is initial on form.
We have ones across the principle diagonal.
we need this to be a six by two because
of the Matrix operation that we're about to perform.
But this is the first eigenvalue.
Second of a second value or if you like the first
singular value in the second singular Valley. Also
if you like the first principle component.
And the second principle component.
Once I start visualizing you will see how this how we're
able to.
Reduce the dimensionality of our data. Now.
How many imagine this were an Excel sheet. We have
two columns of data.
What we're about to do this example is collapse into one column.
So we go from a two-dimensional letter to one dimensional data.
That's a lead. That's the linear transformation to go
from R2 to R.
R 1
Now I also want to do this. I want
to plot this Vector on its own axis.
Plot this on its own axis. So this
will be let's see X
and this will be y
so
Here, we will say performing SVD up.
principal component
SVD
first we need to decompose The Matrix into three matrices.
Then we are going to visualize.
the
column vectors
of a
just so we can have a
intuitive
understanding
Now I'm going to use a technique called a list comprehension. So
if you do not if you haven't seen this before or you
don't remember it.
let me show you I'm going to go a
that's the Matrix and I'm going to use the square bracket, of
course.
If you plug in a number.
And these are the indices the index the every index
will correspond to a particular rule.
of a matrix if I type is 0
this will be the first row of the
original Matrix.
And of course, we remember that we count from 0 and in
programming.
if I want the last row I go I go 5
now if I want all of the rows
What this colon means is that.
What precedes the color is the starting range? And what
comes after is this ending range if I type this if I
leave?
Both sides of the colon empty. That means give me all of
the rows.
So here we can see.
The first row is negative three negative 3
the second was negative 2 negative one. So if I just want the first
two rows I can go 0 1
Or rather zero to that. It has to be stopping an X.
There we go.
Now what I actually want.
Is all of the rows.
But I want to only extract the first column.
So I'm going to call this C1.
and it will be negative 3 negative 2 1 negative 1 2 3
So what I'm going to say is I want all of the rows all of
the rows.
from the first column
and that will give me
these components
Animal, I'll also do it for the second column.
So all of the rows from the second column
again, we count from 0.
Which is why this is one.
Now I'm going to I will plot these two.
Vectors so C1 and C2 are both now vectors.
Okay, however, I'm going to treat these as
points on the x-axis.
And for C2 it will be points on the y-axis. Basically, we
would just draw two.
one horizontal and one
vertical column
and I'll see why and I'll show you why we want to do this.
So to plot I'm going to use the PLT method PLT Dot.
scatter
so I want see you want to be on the x-axis. I'm
going to type in C1.
for the y-axis
we want
I'm going to set it to 0.
Okay.
6 elements corresponding with the six points in
that vector
and then I should have will see as plts.
Yeah, thank you, Ron. I fixed that.
Now I also want to color code these points.
So this will be zero negative 3, excuse me,
negative 3 0 negative 2 0
1 0 C. There's a points right? These are the points corresponding
to the x-axis. These are the points corresponding on the y-axis.
I want to color code is I want to color code the X points
that are
the left of the origin
Beside it. Basically the numbers that are negative will have one
color the numbers that are positive will have another color.
So I'm going to say c c is the parameter for
color.
And the criteria for shooting the color.
is
C1 greater than 0
so if the component has C1 or above 0
we will get one color if they are below zero will get another color.
and we will and let me just set the
the no never mind.
It's going to change Dimensions. Let me see what this looks like.
Okay. There we go.
and I'll do the same for the second column
of Matrix a
maybe what I should have done is typed in make this a1a2.
Make it clear.
Let me run this again.
and then a two
Let's change the order of these arguments.
So the idea is this.
We have two dimensions of data.
these two vectors
and what we want to do is retain this
spread.
this variation
but in one axis in one vector
So when it retains this value.
these
this spread in one diagonal
So here this is one dimension of our data.
the second dimension of our data
however, we want to do is use the
principal components
Which are the eigenvalues?
To collapse this into one access without
mmm while keeping.
This spread as much as possible.
So here's what I'll do next.
I am going to take
the first principle component
multiplied by
the first principle Direction
Let me open this again.
now you
I know it has it's quite
maybe messy.
But the First Column Vector in U is the first principle Direction.
What I'm good at you is I'm going to multiply.
the first principle component by the
principal direction of the Matrix U
Now the principal component is also.
the first principle component
is a component that has that has the largest values if
I come back here.
If we look at this example, this was a completely different
Matrix.
The largest singular value or large eigenvalue. This
Matrix is the number 14.
This number also corresponds in the
context of PCA.
to the
variance and the data
so the first argument value
Is the first principle component and also the
represents the largest variance in
the data?
Now a note instead why we need to keep the variance of the data will
have to look at a second example.
so first
We will focus on visualizing understanding dimensionality
reduction.
And the later on we'll look another example where we have a larger
data set.
And a covariance matrix is involved this example since it's
only two columns is too small.
Okay.
so let's
See the principle. Excuse me.
Let's see the
dimensionality reduction first and then we'll
talk about covaries and correlation matrices.
Okay.
in order to visualize our first
principle component we will take
s if you remember s was
The okay. Why did I not run the celebrity cell
again?
No, I have to run it from the top.
Oh.
yeah, so as
Is the eigenvector?
And this is the largest principle component, which will
be the first person component.
so in order to get the first principle compound, we will use index 0
We will then multiply this by.
The First Column of the Matrix U. So
again if we return to here to this
writing
If this is the Matrix U we're going to multiply this.
principle component by the first principle Direction
So I'm going to multiply this by you.
I want all of the rows.
from
the first column
I run this.
I now have a linear transformation.
We've gone from Matrix 2.
a vector
So this is the vector corresponding to
the first principle component.
I plot this now if I go PLT I
have to code here by the way.
plot
principal component
one
So I'm going to pass this twice.
And let's just call this pc14 by the
way.
pc1
so the points on the both X and Y axis will
be pc1.
It's a line that will go through the origin.
And it will be linear.
Where piece you want the components and pc1 are greater than
zero.
I'm setting the X and Y limits to negative 5 to 5 for
both the X and Y axis because well the components of
the principal components.
Grow from negative 4 to positive 4 so we
just want to make room two so we can see it.
This is the result.
of PCA
we have taken those two dimensions.
Which you can see we're quite spread.
And we have combined both dimensions.
We have combined both vectors into one
vector.
while keeping the variance while retaining
a significant amount of the data
if we do the same thing for the second principle component.
You will see that it retains data, but not
as much as the first one.
This is amazing because
if there was any correlation if there's
any significance any significant relationship between the
two first
a columns
Well now they are let's say merged or
combined it to one.
into one
Dimension so we've gone from two Dimensions to one dimension.
This will become incredibly powerful, especially when we have a larger data
sets.
We go, for example, 20 Dimensions or 15
Dimensions down to one or two or
three principle components making the job of the machine learning model.
a lot easier
now there's more to our discussions. So we haven't even gotten into
discussion of
The covariance Matrix yet
But we'll do that. Let's actually leave this here.
For later reference. Hopefully you've understood what we mean by dimensionality
reduction.
And let's switch to another example.
So we can better appreciate principal components. Actually.
Let me see. What was the agendas our applied was to.
Talk about neural networks. Okay, let's do this. First thing that we will
return to PC.
Let's return to let's switch to neural networks for now and then we'll return
to PCA.
Okay.
I need to pull up another set of slides.
This is from a different presentation. So let me jump to the
relevant.
section
neural networks
All right.
Anyone here have any experience working with neural
networks?
by the way, this this slides are from astral Labs, which
is where I also teach
One says yes, which is no.
Anybody else?
Or Pi torch, okay.
now here, of course our
Focus is not the library.
But the the concepts of neural networks.
So it's with neural networks that we were able to perform deep learning.
Yeah, let's we see why it's called Deep learning. What's why deep?
Let's first start with the most Atomic the most basic
component of a new network. First of all.
Let me take a step back. Let me take a step back.
Let's talk about something a little more basic.
This is a very large presentation.
And talk about artificial intelligence. I'll make
this quick.
Okay. Just want to give you some.
mmm
I'm gonna use two big words here etymological.
and historical context
for artificial intelligence
When we say artificial intelligence, you know, what what is it that comes to mind
we picture.
A situation where we have these humanoids these
Androids these robots.
who are
If not, as if not Superior to us intelligence, they
are equal to wasn't intelligence. Now. You've seen
this in many movies, you know these robots.
They have very human-like.
Intellectual capabilities and there are two two.
What do we call it two?
groups of
thinking
And one group we have people say who advocate for
developing artificial intelligence.
Because you know we can train these robots. We can build these
robots who will help us, you know, improve the quality of
our life.
You know to use economic terms increase improve our
utility.
We can do less work.
whether it's the Warriors work, you know working in
the minds or
You know anything that is physically demanding or
even you know situations like this where you
have to do very laborious.
technical work
These robots can come here and do the work for us
or call at least at the various collaborate with us and you know, make our
lives easier.
And the second group of people have this
perception, right if we make them too smart.
Then it will be a matter of time before they come and take, you know,
come knocking on our doors and well you
get you get the picture.
Process some people think that Google's Lambda neurotic has
become sentient. Yeah. There was this one software review engineer says,
I think it was as machine learning model that has become sentient.
Let me tell you why that's not.
Likely to be true or at least not so
not not just yet. Okay.
There is a there is a one.
Theoretical explanation why?
We cannot produce computers they
can.
extrapolate
learn from extrapolation
and there was also a
practical explanation fire why it's not possible to
create such, you know sentient things.
First let's talk about the three categories of
artificial intelligence.
Okay.
We have the most primitive, which is narrow AI.
And the most Superior which is of course Superior.
Narrow AI is really what we call machine learning.
And another name for machine learning as you may know is statistical learning.
It's really just statistical techniques.
used
on large volumes of data
Basically, it is a lot of the Redundant tasks that a statistics
would do a lot of the basic arithmetic.
There is a decision would do and it is automated with software. That's
what machine learning is machine learning is in very
simple terms statistics.
automated
now obviously there's more to a status
job than
calculating simple things like
dispersion and variation
But a lot of it is automated a
lot of the things that a session would do in order to perform analysis
is very mundane machine learning
automates machine learning about automating most of that.
Okay.
And it will only machine learning model will be useful so
long as there is no such as so long
as there's no significant concept shift now.
Now that I've had Concepts Chef. This is in order to explain what
that is. We have to go to different realm. Basically. It is a significant shift
in the distribution of data and that is the
realm of ml Ops machine learning Ops, by the way, if you
want to know what machine learning obsess I recorded a
Workshop
I just haven't uploaded to the website yet. You
can watch that and you can you can see what that is. So it's about machine learning
put in production. So and these three next workshops. We're going to
look at machine learning on our computers.
but
we don't want to just be on the computer. We want it to be on the cloud. But then
once it's on the cloud you need to monitor it that's what envelopes is about. Anyway, I
just want to let's stick to here and
I'll tell you what we can learn more about machine learning.
Anyway, so we have three layers.
narrow AI is
using machine learning to do very
well narrow tasks, for example.
Speech to text.
For example, it's like
a narrow.
As a human being you're capable of doing many things, correct.
You're able to perform many tasks.
Make a sandwich.
Make a telephone call recognize somebody's
face and greet them and so on.
So all of these are narrow tasks that we are capable of doing
and now ai is using machine learning to machine
learning to do to use one of these to perform one
of these now tasks.
Speech text is an example where you listen to
audio.
And then you make a transcript of it.
If you go to YouTube and you play a video there is the closed
caption option when you click the Switch.
And there is the text corresponding to
the speaking person.
It's not accurate all the time. There's a lot of mistakes in it, but that's an
example of an area.
Another one is image classification what you feed the model of
pictures and the model will say this is a card. This is a truck. This is
a cat Etc.
Now we are currently here.
Generally AI.
Is where we just stage where?
the system we have whether it's using machine learning or a combination of
machine learning and rules-based systems rules bases
you
like
our programming
but the the construction program if and else statements that
kind of thing.
So generally is where we have a system.
That can't that is equal to us.
in a
intellectual capacity
so if you have a system that can
learn like you think like you communicate like
you then we have reached General AI.
Now why is it? Why are we
quite far from getting to Super AI?
In order for us to get to Super AI.
That is a stage where?
Machines are superior to us and intelligence.
Who was first be able to replicate our own intelligence?
It makes sense, right? How can we exceed ourselves if we cannot replicate our
metal capabilities?
that is
getting to generally I so and why are we not able to get the general AI?
because
What is a human being like what what is it? That makes us
intelligent? It's our brain.
Yes.
Well, the thing is we don't know much about we don't know as much about us.
We don't know much about the brain as much as we
want to know
and this is the realm of biology and psychology. We
know a great deal about the paint but not enough to replicate
it.
you know, you've heard the story, you know, what what they
examine Einstein's brain just to see what's going on. We still don't
know. What what's we don't we still don't know all the intricacies of
human brain. So, how can we supersede? How can we ever produce
a just a super? Yeah, if you don't even know how our own
brain work.
And we still here.
So this is a practical explanation. There's also theoretical explanation but
That's discussion for a later time.
having said that
of all the machine learning techniques that we have available to
us deep learning is the most sophisticated why because deep
learning is the is our
attempt to replicate the human brain
as close as possible.
so deep learning
Is how we can never get to this point if we can
get to this point?
So now that we have covered this prerequisite, let's jump
to that slide now.
Where did I put it?
Come on.
It should be.
here
No, so we said deep learning is our attempt to replicate.
the human brain
Of course the brain that we have understood up
to this point in time.
So up here we have.
a diagram
or a pectoral model of a neuron
so this is the most building block basic building block or
you know organic component of the
of the human brain, right? We don't want to go down to subatomic particles
and that kind of thing.
So this is a neuron it has these.
Let's say branches called the dendrites that
receives signals.
electrochemical signals from other neurons
and these signals travel down these dendrites.
And then they are processed by this thing called a nucleus.
If the signal is strong enough.
Then another signal will travel down this Axon.
and all to these other
terminals
and it is at these terminals where we
have connections with other neurons.
So the way we are able to learn things and remember things is
by these electrochemical signals.
firing off
all of our brain
and so we have these neurons come together to form thoughts to
form memories to form ideas.
Okay.
Well, you see here down here is a very abstract diagrammatical
representation of the above.
What we want to do is a mathematically model this neuron.
In deep learning we call the neuron.
the perceptron
So in our brain we have neurons in machine deep
learning we have these things called perceptrons which are supposed
to be.
replicas
Of the neuron that's a perceptron.
so the dendrites
here are the inputs. What are the
inputs?
The inputs are the dimensions.
Or The Columns of the data.
If you if you think for example about
an Excel sheet, I can't use that realistic example.
Size of the property distance to the city center number
of bedrooms.
These are all columns right column vectors.
And each column Vector is an input.
And what's a circle that circle is the well, I'll
show you what the circle is. It's a combination of two things, but it will
be processed here.
and then one
value or one vector will be produced.
from this
N number of vectors, so it's a linear transformation in other words and then
here at the axon you have the option of either
outputting one vector or branching out to three
why?
Do we want to have one of the other world depends on how we have struck to
do neural network?
Let's look at a more mathematical representation of this model
and it's this.
here we have x sub 1 all the way to x sub n
where x sub I
represents a component
of some Vector X. Bye.
We notice the excess here are italic.
So I get to use a real estate example.
Let's say x the vector x sub 1
is the
number of bedrooms
and then x sub 1 could be three bedrooms.
Then the vector X up 2 could be the size of the property in
square feet.
So this will be
2,000 square feet
Right, so this could be three three bedrooms 2,000 square
feet.
So basically all of the
values of the first property
then we have these W's anyone know what these WS are.
Any guesses what w stands for?
Precisely the weights right? We said that
these are all factors that influence the
price of the property.
but
the number of bedroom the size of the apartment the
floor.
Of the apartment.
Whether it has a balcony or not.
It's proximity to the city center. These are
all important factors, but some are more
important than others.
All right. So for example being close to city center
is the most important factor.
So for example, if x sub 3 is the proximity to
the city center, then it will have a much higher weight.
whereas let's say except five, which
is the
I don't know the lighting system, right?
if it's
if the use fluorescent instead of LED
It's a very insignificant. It's something you can change,
you know in an hour or two, but let's say for example
Factor.
It's it's it will have a much smaller weight.
What you do then is you take the product of each X
and its weight.
And then you sum.
So you have product product and then some of the products?
That's the summation here.
And then that value that you will get will be the activation.
now
this activation will be fed into what we call an activation function.
and an activation function is basically
a function that will determine
the threshold of the signals if the signal is strong enough. We'll
pass it on to the next.
perceptron otherwise
We will not send any signal we listen to zero.
For example, why let me give you an example why you would
need to choose an activation function why you would need to
process a signal or not?
Imagine you're looking at a picture.
and let me pull up a picture here picture of a
character
Any kind doesn't matter.
And we want to know what is the number?
in this picture
the way we're going to the way the model is going to look at
this picture is to go through the entire picture
and of course if you remember from session,
I think our very first session we said that pictures will
be represented as a matrices, right? This will be a matrix.
And we said a white pixel is 255.
And a black pixel is zero.
So if we for example look at this.
Section of the picture because we have to go.
from one corner to the next
and process the picture
one super pixel at a time
a super pixel is a collection of pixels.
If we look at this super pixel, everything is white.
There's nothing of
there's nothing here.
So it's activation will be zero.
There's nothing worthwhile. However, if
we make our way here.
Well now we will have a positive activation.
Because we have a line. That's the idea. That's the purpose
of this activation function.
and when we use this activation, we
will be able to narrow down our
we will have another linear transformation.
We will only have the number four and you will
discard the area around.
And then later, what we will do is we will flatten this
Matrix. We'll have another linear transformation.
Where we'll go for example from a 16 by 16.
to a
single vector
So 32.
1 by 32 vector
now why why do we need to do this new transformation? We'll come
back this to the state has to do with distributions. We will leave that
for later.
Well what I want us to First understand is this the main
component of the neural network perceptron now,
why is it called now work? Well because it's a network of
perceptrons.
if you take
those
I think I was demonstrating something. That's
why I have this here. Let me give it up these.
Sorry about that.
if we take
Those perceptions and put them into a network. We will get a neural network.
So all of these circles that you see here.
These are all perceptron perceptron all the
perceptrons.
It's called Deep learning because you know, we have
these layers.
And they can if we stack.
Enough of these layers will have a deep network of perceptrons.
So that's what's called Deep learning.
And this is an example of a fully connected
Network and it's called fully connected because every perceptual is
can it's connected every other perceptron in the
subsequent Network.
Run us are all the layers in this example are then
yes. See this densely. This is all that's correct.
now in a neural network
and a fully connected Network now there are different.
Combinations and why you would choose
one combination versus the next?
We'll have to do with the nature of the data is a pictorial.
Is it sequential like if you want to do Time series?
Time series is where for example like
stocks right the price of the stock.
Goes up and down.
or the weather
you want to see why does the weather go up or down?
And if you see if you could predict it for the next
month or the next.
week
well, the change in temperatures associated with data is
associated with the
Calendar right obviously server, it's warmer when
there is cooler.
or another example is again speech to
text or
Autocomplete, you know when you go to Gmail and you type in
an email you say for example. Hello, Ron.
Please see the and then Gmail completely remaining
sentence. It was a CD attached.
It will like fill in the blank. It will complete your sense.
That is also accomplished using.
a sequential Network
So again, I'll show you different Arrangements. I'll show their pictures
of them, but
there are different ways we can assemble this.
But here again, if you see here we
have the input layer then we have.
A series of hidden layers and then finally an upper layer.
Now why this is have four, for
example, let's say you are doing again one more
time. I'll do the real estate example. You have all
of the features of the property.
And then you're going to learn every single hidden layer in
here.
Is going to learn a wheat?
Basically on one thing I forgot to mention.
here
These weights are randomly assigned.
Because the model does not know.
The significance of the number of bedrooms versus the
significance of the proximity to the city center to
the model. These are all numbers there be nothing.
So it will first randomly assign weights and
then using a what we call.
back propagation
and a technique in
Multivared calculus called gradient descent it
will adjust the weights.
Basically, it will make one round of prediction
compare it to a sample.
And then it will adjust the weights because if you remember we
talked about MSC in our last Workshop. We
said that we want msct conversions you have to convergence
is zero, then what the model predicts and what
the actual prices are will be equivalent. If
the errors are 0 they will be equivalent and that's what
we want ideally.
Initially the model when we first feed the data to the
network the MSC will be large.
But the model will keep looking at the sample again and again
and again and adjust the weights.
Adjust the weight again and again and again and again until it has
understood why one feature is important by other features
not important.
Now again, if you're just trying to predict the
number you'll have only one output.
Which will be the price.
if however we're doing something like
c r n
a convolutional new network where
you're going to go from a matrix data.
to
to a Vertex to a vector
if you're going to be doing this transformation, this is a
linear transformation. Then what what you will append at
the end of the outpole layer could be another Network. You can actually
mix two networks together especially for complex problems.
moving on
this is where the activation function will get this later on.
and like I said
Okay, let me also take you
through this very quickly.
so we have three types of
fundamental networks. We have the multi-layer perceptron
multi-layer perceptrons are sufficient for
Tabular data, so if you have an Excel sheet with five six
seven columns.
And you want to do regression or classification? You can create an
MLP.
And it's very trivial to create an employee with libraries like pytorch
and tensorflow.
if you're going to be dealing with
sick
images especially images of
three color channels and you will use a convolutional neural network
again the word convolution has to do with
This Matrix operation in a convolutional network.
You have two types of matrices The Matrix
representing the picture.
And the Matrix which is the kernel which is
used to.
or lack of whatever words purse to
observe the super pixels
of the picture
I think we've seen this before.
I think I've shown your kernel but not we will look at it. And
then and one of the sessions where we will
do you will use CNN for image recognition and then there's a recurrential network.
Long story short.
You would use MLP if you have simple tabular data, everything is
numerical.
Cnns that we have.
You know.
Square matrices anything that needs to be put in
scrimmage like a picture or videos after all videos are sequence
of pictures.
And our events if you have sequential data.
for time series for
speech to text or text to speech for set table
analysis.
by the way, if any of you are interested in
predicting stock
Is what predicting stock prices it's very problematic because
something you really can't really can't do
but beside if you're interested in.
You know buying and selling stocks.
Well the price of a stock.
Is strongly influenced by public opinion?
And so there are some companies that use sentiment
analysis to see what people are saying about certain topic.
Like what was that stock game Gamestop?
right
and people will
what was the what they were using when they were on Twitter?
opposite of Short Selling
opposite of shooting
longing right they were
trying to Long the game start by showing people were talking
about the old Nokia or all the you
know,
electronic
forms of entertainment and so they were making
the making the price go up. So as people's basically you
could you set them analysis to see you are people
sentiment positive about this topic.
The price is going up. Let's buy it.
If the if people are saying negative things, let's say
I don't know the CEO of this particular company said something
very terrible. Well something very racist or
sexist or whatever and the price is going to drop and so
you can use sentiment last to detect that and then start
shorting or just start selling.
Exactly wrong.
So now of course.
Getting access to the data is another story.
Then a bunch of Nursery going to stop exactly
yeah as as to retaliate.
It's very fascinating story. But yeah that my point is this
without going to off topic here you if you
have if you want to process sequential data like
anything do with time.
or words or
Yeah, sound bites you won't use RNs.
But of course, like I said you can we can combine.
Like for one problem that I'm working on I'm using a drnn.
Which is a combination of convolutional networks and
recurring units because what I want to do is go from
pictures.
to
a sequence of characters
Basically, I think I talked about this. I
want to look at a mathematic a picture of an equation.
And converted to a later code
which is a sequence of characters.
Yeah, and thank you one for sharing the the background
of that GameStop scenario.
So yeah, we'll set up allows us you can see you know, what people are talking about and
then react.
preemptively
Okay.
Now there are stuff. This slides have
to do with the math Market representation.
Here's an example of using a CNN for pictures.
So for example, you take this picture of a cat.
And this picture of the cat is colored. So you have at
least three color channels red green and blue.
and each
channel will be put into its own Matrix, which we call
a
two-dimensional convolutional
layer, it's called two of you because we have two dimensions
for each color Channel.
And it's called the convolution because we're going to convolve.
the kernel
with
each
color Channel
now I will show you convolution in a separate session, but the
idea is in this particular architecture you will go
from
the picture to a flat Factor
again a linear transformation
and this flat
vector
will correspond to the distribution
Again by the way, yes matrices
are very important for new Networks.
But at the end of the day, this is still machine learning statistical
learning. So distributions are very very important.
if you curious about distributions, that's
the next course, which begins
Sometime later in the second
or third week Vlog is anyway, let's
come back here.
And this let me show you one last thing and
Let's begin with the basics of the what code we're not quite done
with this. There's quite a lot to cover here.
But let me just show you.
the mathematical representation of
a neural network
I can find that that is.
Here we go.
This equation is from a book.
from charu Agarwal a very
popular author of all kinds of machine learning
books
And he's very well written I would strongly recommend
any of his books. He has a book on.
Machine learning for text. I recommend it. He has a book on data mining.
I recommend it. He's a book on using
machine learning or data money for healthcare. I recommend
that too. In fact, I recommend all of his books, but here
let's just pay attention to this the formula.
We want to understand the formula here.
We can see we have w.
Now this author I guess does not use the Bold.
Convention, I would prefer that they did.
But that's the Matrix the transpose of the Matrix multiplied by
the scalar value, which here is the mean?
of the data
this five function is the activation function what I
try to really say, is that a neural network?
Is linear algebra?
So what we're going to do is look at we will look at the mathematical representation
of it.
And look at it in its python
implementation.
but we'll start with the python implementation first because that's
we want to get the ball rolling ball rolling.
Okay.
so we want to understand the
terms here the symbols here. What's what exactly
like what's this calculation?
and then
you know, we will have a thorough and foundational understanding
of
a neural networks
Okay.
We have 20 minutes left. So let me do
this as fast and
the optimal way
let me open up the reference code.
I have a few notebooks. I want
to see this simplest one.
This is for image classification.
And this is for predicting realistic properties.
Yeah, I think we can use this.
Okay, let me use this notebook.
So as opposed to typing it from scratch.
I'm going to show you the whole thing and then we will break it
down.
I'll break down the code but
There is the we need to cover some more we
need to cover.
some prerequisites in statistics and
multivared calculus
I already have a video for that. So I will tell you
what to find. It's on YouTube.
I'll post a video in the slack Channel.
So let's begin.
We have pandas.
Pandas is a library that extends the capabilities
of numpy.
It extended by.
Turning a numpy array into a thing called
a data frame.
And it's data frames
are really good because you can convert an
Excel sheet into a python.
object
so you can see the column names of the CSV file
or Excel file or tsv file?
You can perform summary statistics.
for some reason statistics
or what actually what I should say is descriptive statistics.
So we have the descriptive statistics, which is very basic stuff.
And then there's inferential statistics. This is
the most sophisticated.
In descriptive statistics, we want to see for example, what is
what are the averages the mean median and mode?
That's what we call measures of.
Central tendency like what is
it centered?
and the second part of
descriptive statistics is measure of variance.
Or other measures of this Persian.
How much variation do we have in data, you know how much variation we
have? And what is the center of the data? We can approximate the
shape of data and knowing the shape of data is
a huge huge deal.
And if you want to know why I'll in that video. It's
a one video and that one video. I
will talk about distributions and gradient descent
and that should give you a good enough.
Review of probably talking about in the
subsequent sessions or even in here.
So we will have what pan doesn't have carrots caress.
Is a library birth on top of tensorflow basically the
abstracts away some of the complexities of potential
flow. So if you want to build a quick simple neural network,
you may you want to go with Keras as opposed
to tensorflow.
And here we are going to create a sequential model why sequential because
we can have a sequence of layers.
input layer
a few or several hidden layers and then an
upper layer.
Of course, but we want to we need to put layers inside
the sequence. So we're going to import everything again
the star meets everything. So from carrots that
layers we will import everything all the layers.
Another important part of machine learning is evaluating the
model.
But I believe that for later.
This is for mother to be evaluation.
We have the CSV data.
Which you I'll show you right right down below.
And I will give this file to you later.
We will import instead of using pandas.
Sorry about that. We will import the data using pandas.
And you will visualize the first five rows. That's
what the head method does.
You can see here we have.
the year built
the number of stories
and the number of
one story house two story house
the number of bedrooms
the number of full bathrooms. I have
patterns four bathrooms our bathrooms that contain, you know
showers or bats.
Now one thing you'll notice is that these numbers.
are normalized
so no value goes between no everybody numbers between
0 and 1.
now of course is a way we can normalize this data using
psychic learn
Cyclone is a library for machine learning.
But this data this this data has been normalized.
So for example
If let's say one of the let's say
we were we have one property that
has six.
Bathrooms, it's a very spacious house.
Got Penthouse or something.
then
if when we know what is it or if
you
If we if we normalize that this will be this will have
the number one.
the highest number of full bathrooms
So if you want to know how many yeah, if
you want to know for example, how many bathrooms?
This apartment has you will multiply six by
zero point.
one two five
Okay, this is not even one. So I think the part I
think the property with the most.
Number of bathrooms was something like 8 or 10. I
have to look at the original data.
But you get the idea.
Yeah.
And suppose we have one that same property
had four stories. That was a very large house. So 0.35. Well,
that's just the one story house.
Now we did some data cleaning before
we got this. So if you see here this data set is called how data
set.
house data set
scaled
so in this notebook in this Jupiter notebook, I'm skipping
the
data cleaning part
Anyway, this is the this is an
end dimensional data as you can see. It's so big that I
cannot even fit and we have these three dots.
I think
there were I don't know they were
definitely more than 20.
Columns this Matrix. So it's a very large Matrix.
For this we would PC would be very helpful.
Anyway, that's the data set. We can preview with the
word pandas.
and
let me skip to discussion about labels and features because we haven't
talked about yet.
And let me skip the train test split part. Let me show you how to create
a sequence of neural networks.
So here what we do is we have the sequential class and we know
classes because classes begin with an uppercase
letter.
Anytime you see some function or a
variable.
Spelling uppercase. That's a class.
Which means we can instantiate it and this will become an object and
what we do what we know about what we know about objectives that
we have attribution properties.
So one of the properties of the sequential
object is at
So here we are adding a densely connected.
Excuse me.
a dense
input layer
we have
63 inputs
and 50
outputs so if I go to that slide
That's fully connected Network.
If you see here.
We are talking about.
this part
So we have 63 Dimensions here. We have Harmony to
me here the input dimensions are what one two,
three, four, five six, seven eight.
And the output dimensions are one two, three, four,
five six, seven eight nine.
So input dimensions are 8 output dimensions are
9.
Now there is by the way, there is no precise formula for
deciding the number of output dimensions.
And there are some experimentation involved.
Tensorflow has something called The tensional Playground, which is
a very nice visual way for you to
see how neural networks work. But again because we
don't have much time. I'm gonna leave that for a later session anyway.
input dimensions
output Dimensions, so we actually create the first
hidden layer and the first input layer in tensorflow.
in one go
Okay, so here.
This is the first input layer and the head
layer in one go. So the input Dimensions the number of incoming.
features and the number of perceptions
activation functional architecture. I'm really sorry about this.
I don't mind it's very sensitive activation function. Like I told
you is how you process the signal.
the value the rectified
linear something. I forgot the name.
is used
is actually a very
effective activation function
But in order for me to show you why it's affected by we have to leave that
for a separate session.
Well, let me just run through this as quickly as I can. So the first
input slash hidden layer
And then the other hidden layers.
So this one has this one will receive.
A 50 inputs from the previous layer and output
100 layers.
Why 100 because we want to learn as many weights as we can.
And then another hidden layer and then file the upper layer
and here we can see we've set the output to 1.
Why 1 well because we want a single value. We want
a single.
numeric
estimate for any given
property
you can see here. We once we have
created a sequence of layers. We will then compile it.
then we have
a loss function again. The Lost function is how we evaluate the
prediction quality of this model. We
said that we want the MSU to converge to zero.
So if you see here.
When we train it.
It's a scientific notation. It says 0.00.
0 1 7 7 160
and as
it keeps on learning.
You can see the MSC starts to grow smaller. So
you can see this and went from E minus
zero fourth e minus zero five. So that's one more
zero next to it.
So it's even closer and closer to zero every
Progression of time sometimes it will
go up a little bit. But ultimately.
It should converge to zero.
If it does not conversion 0 and it's instead it
diverges. Well, then there was something wrong with the code
you've done.
Okay.
anyway
This is how we this is one metric by
what you will determine the quality of the model. That's MSC.
And then there's something called the optimizer algorithm
the atom algorithm again. I'm not going to talk about it here. It's in
that video. I told you about it has to do with gradient descent.
Let me scroll down some more.
So after we evaluate the metrics for the
data.
We can see for the training data set. It is 0.0.
well
That's 5073. So it's very close to zero.
This is a good this is a good model.
And for test study it's even smaller still.
For test it's even smaller still.
Have you as anyone heard of overtrained overfitting underfitting?
Anybody else if you've not heard of overfitting an underfitting
type and in the chat in the window?
Now very quickly. The reason we use training test is
to quickly identify over affirming
underfitting.
I reason underfitting is when the
model has not learned anything in particular.
And you can detect underfitting at the training stage.
So if the number is high.
You don't even to proceed the test dataset.
It's already bad.
The way you will detect a overfitting is where you have
a good.
training metric
But then for the test metric it does worse.
So if your training metric is here, which is that's
a good this is good and then it goes up. That's over a very
If it's high to start with that's underfitting.
So that's why we need to look at trade and test.
And unless we've done this we have created for ourselves a machine learning
model they can predict.
You can see here using the predict method.
And then this is the final price.
of one particular property
So what we're going
to do is I'm going to post this notebook with some
additional comments in the dashboard.
And we want to actually know.
Before we get into our next session. I strongly recommend.
that if you're not familiar with
test dataset train dataset
Machinery metrics and Grading this in
a particular that you watch that video.
Let me just
pull up the link very quickly. Although I'm gonna Post in the slack
Channel.
The video is called mathematics for machine learning you may have.
attended the event
Okay.
And there are also timestamps so you can jump to the section that is
relevant to you.
now
So please watch this it's only an hour. Although you may
not even have to watch the entire hour.
Just have a look at that before you join the next session.
so
If I return to our agenda.
so now we've covered a
we've had the high level overview of
deep learning and it's infrastructure called new
networks. We've talked about these three components.
You know next Workshop. I'm going to show you how to do PCA for.
a more useful data set and then
we will go ahead and use neural networks for
first regression and then
image classification
and our last session we can use we will look at neural networks
for
sequential data
I think we have enough.
I think for the most part everyone's more comfortable with the
mathematics so we can
Move more quickly, of course, I have other notebooks.
There are many other examples of Google networks that you know,
we won't be able to look at because there's just not enough time, but I'm
gonna include them as examples and they will all be accompanied by
comments.
so you can watch those and then
you know.
Use those as reference to help you solve the assignment for
module 4.
Okay, and by the way speaking of assignments.
The assignments from module two and three will be put on the dashboard today.
And the assignment for module 4 at the end of module 4.
So you'll have one week after the end of module 4 to complete the
assignment.
Okay.
Any quest for comments, by the way?
About today's session about the subsequent sessions about
the previous sessions or anything in particular.
You see there's so much.
topics to cover
I in this session the past session I don't
even have time to
You know make it to give you an exercise.
So I want to at least use this minute to answer any questions
you have.
Anything that you would like to be covered anything that
has but there is of interest to you.
I'm just auditing and then oh, okay. So
the access to the dashboard thing is automated.
So if you were not verified.
You would need to yeah, you would need to be verified to access
it. Okay?
I'm going to ask the yeah, I'm
gonna ask.
You might you should have everyone should have
received an email from support about upgrading this certification.
If you did not receive it or if what I'll
do is I'll ask.
And the organizer to send another email.
And then she'll follow up with you.
Okay.
But yeah, if you do think of if there's something that
you want to cover.
That is not part of the syllabus or something. We haven't
covered up this point.
Let me know because I I want to
make the you know, the curriculum as an
interesting to you as possible.
Okay, let me just post this link.
And yes, so, please watch this video before the next session.
Thank you for joining me.
And I hope to see you on Wednesday everybody.
Thank you so much.
For now. Take care. Bye.